تحدثت صحيفه ليبراسيون الفرنسيه عن ظروف
الولاده المرعبه التي تعيشها النساء في
قطاع غزه بسبب الحرب وتنقل الصحيفه عن
باسكال كوسار منسقه الطوارئ لمنظمه اطباء
بلا حدود في غزه شهادتها عن محنه النساء
الحوامل في القطاع بين المستشفيات المقتضى
ونقص المعدات وقالت كواسر ان العديد من
النساء يلدن في اماكن غير المستشفيات
وبعضهن انجبن في خيامه والبعض الاخر في
المراحيض في مناطق النازحين المنتشره في
انحاء
رفح في تقرير من رام الله قالت صحيفه وول
ستريت جورنال ان اسرائيل تكثف هجماتها على
الفلسطينيين في الضفه الغربيه التي اصبحت
جبهه مميته بشكل متزايد في صراع امتد الى
ما هو ابعد من الحرب في غزه وتضيف الصحيفه
ان مسؤولي الامن الاسرائيليين يشيرون الى
الضفه الغربيه باعتبارها الجبهه الثالثه
في الحرب بعد غزه والحدود الشماليه
لاسرائيل مع لبنان ومع ذلك فان حملتها
القمعيه في الضفه الغربيه تمثل معضله
امنيه راى تقرير في مجله الايكونوميست ان
الحرب في غزه ستستمر في التاثير في
اسرائيل حتى بعد انتهائها واوضحت الصحيفه
ان تركيز اسرائيل منصب حاليا على معاركها
المباشره في غزه ومصير اكثر من 130 ره
مازالوا محتجزين هناك ولكن من الواضح على
نحو متزايد انه حتى بعد انتهاء القتال فان
تاثير هذه الحرب سوف يظل محسوسا لسنوات
عديده على استراتيجيه اسرائيل العسكريه
وبالتالي على
اقتصادها قالت صحيفه فاينانشال تايمز ان
الانقسام الحاد في قياده الحرب
الاسرائيليه ظهر الى العلن بعد ان دع رئيس
الاركان السابق جادي ايزنكوت الى اجراء
انتخابات في غضو د اشهر وقال ان الحكومه
لم تكن صادقه مع الجمهور بشان هجومها ضد
حماس ونقلت الصحيفه عن مصادر مطالعه ان
رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي بنيامين نتنياهو
ووزير دفاعه يو اف جالانت بالكاد يتحدثان
مع بعضهما اجرت صحيفه معاريف استطلاعا
للراي اظهر ان 50% من الاسرائيليين يرون
ان بيني جانس اكثر ملائمه لمنصب رئيس
الوزراء من بنيامين نتنياهو الذي صوت له
31% فقط من المستطلع ارائهم وحسب
الاستطلاع فانه اذا اجريت انتخابات كنيست
جديده فسيحصل ائتلاف نتنياهو على 44 مقعدا
مقابل 71 مقعدا لاحزاب المعارضه ولن يحصل
حزب عس ما يهوديت الذي يتراس بن كفير الا
على تسعه مقاعد